hello my name is John Asmus I'm a
professor at Georgetown McDonough School
of Business and the Georgetown Law
Center and I'm at reasons headquarters
in Los Angeles and I'm here to talk to
you about a familiar and conventional
argument for the government for
government regulation of the marketplace
it's usually referred to as the market
failure argument I want to suggest to
you that there may be some flaws with
that argument so let me begin by
describing the argument the argument
goes like this
markets are generally a good thing when
people buy and trade buy and sell and
trade and interact with each other on a
market then both parties are better off
after the exchange than before I give
someone something that I want less in
return for something I want more the
other party there's the same thing after
the trade we both are better off in
societies actually more prosperous so
that's why markets a good they increase
the sum total of wealth and society and
you want people to engage in this kind
of activity but it's that's not always
the story in some cases there's more
that takes place which is if I buy and
sell with someone else
our activities might impose some costs
on other people that are not part of the
transaction which we don't take into
account so an example would be people
would like to have inexpensive linen
shirts and I have a factory where I can
make the shirts and I would like to
increase my financial wealth I make the
shirts I sell them the people get the
shirts they're better off I get the
income I'm better off but what's not
taken into account is my factory burns
coal coal goes up through the smokestack
it goes into the atmosphere and it falls
down on the surrounding neighbors land
and they have a cost that's not taken
into account in our transaction and
that's often referred to as the social
cost of private transactions if I was to
speak in economic terminology the
economists would call that a negative
externality
the private transaction sometimes these
spillover effects or social costs can be
so large that the cost to society is
actually larger than the gain that comes
from the trade and in cases like that
the argument goes what happens is the
private transactions are actually
reducing social wealth and not
increasing it and I understand the
terminology correct what that's
described as as a market failure the
market is failing to deliver something
that's wealth enhancing and in those
cases what we need is something to
correct the market failure and the
argument is that you need governmental
regulation to internalize these negative
externalities or to deal with these
social costs and that's in cases like
that
that's why government regulation of the
market is well justified so that's my
description of the argument I'm going to
suggest to you that there's a few
problems with this argument but to
explain why let me put on the screen
something that depicts the relationship
between the law and the market that this
argument appears to be based on the
argument I just described views the
marketplace has the realm of unregulated
voluntary transactions it's what people
do when they're completely free from
regulation if use the law as the realm
of regulation of voluntary transactions
for the public good and the interest of
the overall public and the way the
screen has it depicted this sees the
market and the law as completely
separate realms there's no overlap
market is voluntary transactions and
then the law is the government coming in
and regulating it I think the problem
with the argument is that this is an
incorrect depiction of both the law and
the market and I'll try to explain why
let me begin with the law at the law for
in the 21st century most of us conflate
the law with legislation legislation are
the rules of law that are created by the
political representatives whether
the local state or federal level people
are elected and there you go into
Congress they passed bills the president
signs it and now you have a law that's
legislation legislation is really part
of our law but it's not all of the law
and most people think of it as all of
the law most of the law that makes our
commercial society go was never
legislated we're a common law culture
and it came from a common law process
the rules of property law the rules of
contract law the rules of commercial law
the rules of tort law which I'll talk
about today even most of the rules of
criminal law never came about through a
legislative process they evolved over
time from the settlement of actual
disputes the common law is called the
common law because these were the
customary laws of England as they were
applied in the King's Royal Courts and
the it's it's accurate to say that this
is customary law and common laws today
usually identified with judge-made law
in the 20th and 21st century that may
not be that accurate inaccurate but
historically that isn't accurate
it wasn't that judges made the law it's
that if a long line of cases were
settled in the same way then that
represented the customary practice and
it was recognized by the courts so
traditionally over the in the formative
period of the common law where the rules
under which we live now we're actually
developing what was happening was
experience was teaching people how to
solve disputes in a way that allowed
them to cooperate and that's where the
common law came from this is evidenced
by William Blackstone definition of the
common law he's the famous English
commentator on the law his definition of
the common law was is the quote general
customs which are the universal rule of
the whole kingdom and form the common
law in its stricter and more usual
signification so the common law I'm
talking about the common law that's case
generated law that arises for
the settlement of actual disputes it's
law that evolves over time in response
to what allows people to cooperate and
the common law is the law that's created
law that is a product of human action
but not a product of human design
nobody consciously makes it it comes
about as a result of human interaction
but the main example that I'll talk
about today is tort law that's what I
teach at Georgetown tort law is the law
that governs stranger interactions when
one party harms another in some way and
the basic rule of tort law is that if
one party acts in a way that imposes an
unconsented to harm on a third party on
another party the injured party may
bring a suit to recover damages to
obtain an object injunction to stop the
activity or both and none of the rules
of tort were enacted by legislatures
they evolved over time in response to
what allowed people to live together
peacefully so that's actually the
majority of our law and tort law still
if we can sue for assault battery
negligence trespass nuisance it covers
all of the ways in which we can
negatively affect each other that's the
majority of our law legislation is truly
part of our law legislation is the part
of our law that consists of general
rules created by political
representatives that apply to all
citizens in a jurisdiction now we all of
us that were properly educated in public
schools in the United States we were
taught to understand why that's a good
thing we were taught this democratic
theory legislators represent the will of
the public and they enact measures
designed to achieve the public good
we're taught that but very few of us
believe it anymore for no one who
supports campaign finance legislation
believes that democratic theory
otherwise they wouldn't be supporting
campaigns finance regulation most of us
can remember the debates that took place
over the Affordable Care Act in 2010
anybody observing that would find it
difficult to think that the individual
legislators were simply trying to do
what was going to be in the public
interest rather than in the particular
interest of his or her constituents the
those of you that are familiar with
public choice economics don't need me to
try to convince you of this and I
wouldn't but that one brief story to
illustrate the true nature of
legislation back in 1994 when the
Republicans were taking over Congress
George Mitchell then the Senate Majority
Leader was retiring and he left office
with perhaps the highest reputation for
integrity of any politician in my
lifetime and when he was retiring he did
an interview on the radio and the
interviewer asked him a question which
was that this is a tough job you're here
for long hours you have to deal with all
these prickly personalities and what
makes the job worthwhile and he told a
little story and the story he told was
the Clinton administration was going to
issue an executive order to require the
federal government to use only recycled
paper but he represented Maine and Maine
is where the paper mills are and they
make new paper and if that regulation
effect executive order went through it
would affect his state negatively and
because he had this position of power he
was the Senate Majority Leader he was
able to kill the executive order and in
the story he tells a story he's back at
Maine and he's giving a speech and
afterwards a man comes rushing up to him
and at first his bodyguards thought he
was being attacked but it wasn't that
this man came up and he had tears in his
eyes and he wanted to shake George
Mitchell's hands and he said how
important it was to him and his
well-being and his family that he could
keep his job they just wanted to thank
him for that and George Mitchell
finished the story by saying it's that
that makes the job worthwhile
now this is the politician that left
office with the highest reputation for
integrity of anyone and he's telling you
the truth what he's telling you the
truth is the purpose of having
legislative power is to thwart the
public good in order to protect your own
particular parochial
interest which is exactly what that
story tells right a realistic view of
legislation is not regulation of
voluntary transactions for the public
good its regulation of voluntary
transactions to serve whatever it is a
politically dominant interest for good
or for ill so that I think is a more
realistic way of depicting it all right
that's my recap miry characterization of
the law all right let me try to
recharacterize the market as well I um I
understand I'm a treasons headquarters
I'm gonna say this nevertheless I
there's no such thing as the realm of
unregulated voluntary transactions right
that doesn't exist economists often will
talk about the realm of unregulated
voluntary transactions because they're
doing some kind of theoretical reasoning
physicists physicists talk about perfect
vacuums but they don't think perfect
vacuums exist in the real world we're
human beings we always function under
some type of restraint we always
function under some type of regulation
the most powerful regulatory force in
the real world is our ethical beliefs
our religious beliefs and our ethical
beliefs curtail the way we act towards
others it regulates our behavior
it's a powerful important regulatory
force perhaps equally important is the
effect of common practices in order to
keep to deal with other people in a way
that is successful we have to know what
to expect of each other and the common
practices tell us what to expect when
you take somebody from the Midwest and
you put them in another country where
the practice is to bargain and somebody
gives them a price and he takes it that
person doesn't understand how to
interact properly so the nature of
common practices also regulate how we
interact with each other in our system
in the anglo-american legal system civil
liability the common law also regulates
how we interact and the last regulatory
force is that legislation can regulate
the market there's always some form of
regulation
now what can the term market mean in the
real world not in the academic
conception but in the real world if I
want to use that term meaningfully
there's got to be some form of
regulation so I'll propose the following
I think the way to use the term market
when you're referring to a free-market
it's the way human beings interact when
they're free from political restraint
when they're free from governmental
regulation that means I'm what the free
market is the market in which we act
with each other on the basis of
constraints from our ethical beliefs
customary practices and the common law
that's the free market and then
sometimes there's political regulation
as well so if I've done a good job of
recharacterizing both of those then I'll
suggest that there's a different
relationship between the law and the
market I've called this the real world
conception because it's not the kind of
argument that PhD economics economists
or political scientists make but if we
recap dereyes things then you want to
see the market as the realm of voluntary
transactions that are regulated by
ethics common practices custom and civil
liability or the common law what's the
law the law correctly understood is
legislation like legislation is
regulation of voluntary transactions to
serve the politically dominant interest
and also besides legislation it's the
common law civil liability that's both
part of the law if you understand the
law in the market the way I've just
described it then they're not separate
realms and they overlap and where they
overlap is with regard to the common law
the common law is part of the law but
it's also part of the market because
it's part of the markets natural
regulatory element so if I used economic
language again I would say there's a
regulatory force that's endogenous to
the market the market has its own
built-in regulatory mechanism and that's
a common law or civil liability
I so given this the next question would
be how effective is the markets own
internal regulatory mechanism tort law
well according to almost everyone today
it's too effective we have a tort reform
movement because businesses are
complaining that civil liability is
putting too much restriction on market
activity in the in 2000 when Ed Rendell
the present governor of Pennsylvania was
chair of the Democratic National
Committee he perhaps inadvertently told
the truth in public when he was speaking
to a meeting of the plaintiffs bar
trying to raise money for Al Gore in
which he said quote that trial lawyers
paved the way for America's consumer
safety advances 80 to 90% of those
safety advances came from litigation
what's protecting our safety it's civil
liability if 80 to 90 percent of the
regulation comes from civil liability
how much is left over as necessary for
it to come from political branches if
most people if they talk about tort law
they've only heard of one case that's
the McDonald's coffee cup case and
they've heard of it as though that's a
bad case or there's something aberrant
about it let me tell you about the
McDonald's coffee cup case McDonald's
served coffee at 185 degrees Fahrenheit
and at that temperature coffee will
cause third-degree burns on a human
human skin within two to seven seconds
too quickly for you to get it off your
clothes or wipe it off McDonald's had
been sued 700 times by people who've
been burned by the coffee not people who
spilled into themselves sometimes it was
spilled on them by McDonald's employees
they knew about the danger they didn't
change it one day a woman came up her
son was driving gave her a cup of coffee
she opened it in a foolish way and
spilled it on her lap and suffered
third-degree burns when this came to
trial her lawyer presented the facts to
the jury
said you've got to tell McDonald's that
they can't keep endangering the public
this way and he suggested that the jury
give his client punitive damages equal
to two days worth of profits that
McDonald's make serving coffee and the
jury did that the next day as I was
driving into Georgetown on the radio
there was a report that pointed out that
every single fast-food restaurant the
United States now served coffee at a
hundred and fifty seven degrees
centigrade Fahrenheit and at that
temperature takes 60 seconds across
third-degree burns the entire population
of the country was now safe from this
kind of injury because of one little old
lady's tort suit you may argue that
that's too much regulation what you can
argue is that it's not enough all right
the internal regulatory mechanism of the
common law the tort system is providing
a great deal of regulation so much
regulation that people sometimes think
that we have too much I've given that I
mean revisit the market failure argument
with which I started I'll submit to you
now that the way I described it at first
makes no sense it could make sense but
for the market failure argument to make
sense it would have to be something like
this when people transacting business in
the real world market that's the market
in which they are restrained by ethical
beliefs common practices and civil
liability and the common law when in
that world in that market there
nevertheless are some spillover effects
or social costs that aren't already
taken care of then you would need
government regulation to deal with those
kind of spillover effects but when you
see it that way the question that comes
to mind is what's an example of that
it's hard to find examples of
unintuitive externalities when you take
into account the effect of tort law I
guess I can leave it to you to come up
with some but let me end with an
illustration and the illustration is the
B
P case that mr. B P spilt a lot of oil
in the Gulf of Mexico a few years ago BP
was vilified for this what caused the
oil spill was that a market failure or
was it something else all right I'm
gonna let me talk to you a little bit
about BP BP in a market couldn't be
drilling at the bottom of the Gulf of
Mexico it was a drilling a mile deep at
that level the risk of a spill you can't
get down to do anything about the risk
of the spill was so great that you would
have virtually unlimited civil liability
you'd be on the hook for billions and
billions of dollars and as a result
market the market with civil liability
discouraged anyone from drilling at the
bottom of the Gulf of Mexico the
internal regulatory mechanism would not
permit that to take place because the
activity was unreasonably risky so how
could BP v Joe be drilling that the
federal government divided up the floor
of the Gulf of Mexico into oil leases
and then it tried to encourage companies
to pay it right to drill oil there but
of course companies won't buy oil leases
if they can't get insurance they can't
buy oil leases to do something that
subjects them to unlimited liability
it's unreasonably dangerous so the next
thing you have to do if the federal
government wants to make money is cap
liability and the federal government did
that in in 1990 with the Oil Pollution
Act you can see up there that the Oil
Pollution Act of 1990 says that take the
upper limit of civil liability for oil
spills is 75 million dollars well that's
something that big oil companies can
handle now it makes economic sense for
them to be drilling at the bottom of the
Gulf of Mexico of course the federal
government said don't worry about it
because will replace civil liability the
common law regulation with political
regulation and so they gave us the
minerals management service as the
regulatory agency
yeah you're smiling because you remember
that group right they were getting a lot
of dinners bought for them by the oil
company and not just dinners some other
less reputable things the agency was
completely captured by the industry that
was supposed to regulate it and in fact
the regulatory body had signed off on
all of the guests dangerous techniques
that BP was using so the comparative
assessment here is between the kind of
regulation you get on the market civil
liability which would have meant so that
there couldn't be an oil spill because
businesses can't afford to engage in
this unreasonably risky behavior and
regulation from the political branches
which legislation is law that serves the
politically dominant interest and in the
Gulf states the oil interest is a pretty
powerful interest and they wanted a
liability cap they got it and the result
was the BP oil spill so there's a
comparative assessment for you to make
I'll submit that the market itself has a
built-in regulatory mechanism that is
very very powerful not subject to
political manipulation and serves the
purpose perhaps better than the kind of
regulation you get out of the political
agencies Thanks